it's almost like I found a loophole I
can I can live rentree and you know
unfortunately people are losing their
homes over it I mean they're they're
they're taking everything from these
homeowners hi my name is Flash Shelton
I'm the founder of the United handyman
Association and I help people remove
their
squatters the thing that I've I think
summarized the most from
2023 is that um a lot of people in this
country
are um you know they they might have an
issue with something and they might talk
about it and they might vent about it
and they might go on social media about
it but when it comes to actually doing
something I I don't know if people are
afraid to put themselves out there or
afraid to put their name on something
you know our country is so upside down
in so many ways not just squatter issues
there are a lot of issues that we need
to deal with and and I I don't think
we're finding a way to deal with them
and coming together regardless of
political party coming together
squatting affects everyone and it
doesn't it doesn't you know it's not
blurred by
lines